ranger zickle they say there are no dumb
questions but why do i still feel dumb
asking it also is that a wall behind you
ginger next time you do answering your
medical questions could you please tell
me why i can feel an invisible pair of
glasses on my face
is it because you normally wear glasses
and you think yours are still on i need
more ginger give me more ginger tetr
tetris is my tetris is me game i don't
know why i put a little lisp on there
question why do your taste buds go crazy
when you're sick
i don't think it's so much your taste
buds i think when you're sick your nose
gets congested so you can't smell
properly and a big
factor in how you perceive taste comes
from your ability to smell foods so when
your nose is congested and you aren't
properly smelling the foods you also
can't taste them well i'm sure there's
also something to be said about the
inflammation that's going back going on
in the back of your throat your tonsils
that could potentially also cause a
problem for you and your taste buds
maybe make them a little bit less
sensitive and also if you have a
congested nose you're more likely to
mouth breathe at night which dries
everything up can also affect your taste
buds
multifactorial
answer naranjo question to dr mike is it
true that it is better for your
digestion if you don't drink while
eating
i have not seen this substantiated i
actually enjoy drinking while i'm eating
and i don't mean drinking alcohol i mean
drinking liquids like water i feel like
it helps me move the food along i think
it's something we recommend as doctors
also drinking water will actually expand
your stomach and make you feel fuller so
maybe encourage you to eat less vichy
price okay here's my question how are
your doctor with the strong gag reflex
explained i don't know i've managed to
control it it's tough but with time you
gain experience and you learn how to
meditate away your fears and
uncomfortableness
megan doaden hard hitting question
that's the only kind of questions i want
on my responding to comment section what
does bear's diet look like what is your
favorite brand of dog food and what is
his favorite treat what is his cheat
snack first of all bear is an absolute
vacuum cleaner whatever i put in front
of him he just goes
sometimes i feel like he forgets to
swallow because
he forgets to chew recently his favorite
snack has been lamb ears
but something that i always do is i
always give bear carrots he loves
chewing on carrots they're healthy safe
for dogs and i give him like four or
five baby carrots and he's like the
happiest noof in the world
tom hutch videos 96 can chest
compression stop the heart if the heart
is already beating first of all i'll
answer this question in a different way
not the way you probably wanted it don't
do chest compressions if someone's
heart's beating the purpose of doing
chest compressions is when the heart's
not beating i guess you're asking if you
aren't sure if the heart's beating well
look if the person's completely
unconscious and they're not breathing
odds are their heart's not beating so go
ahead and do chest compressions call for
help first of course janine fernando
what's your opinion on split sleeping
two to three hours in the morning five
to six in the evening is it healthy i
don't like it yes there is some benefit
to taking a little siesta when your
circadian rhythm dips in
in the midday phase but i think split
sleeping like that just i don't see
evidence for it what i see evidence for
is sleeping seven to nine hours of
consistent steady sleep of the same time
at night and then if you need to taking
a short 15 to 30 minute nap in the
middle of the day when your circadian
rhythm takes a little dip around 1 2 p.m
now we just got to get those napping
pods in all our offices then we'll be
all set and actually get our bosses to
allow us to do the nap
arrow jade i have a very random and
interesting question is the study of
dreams and how they work a profession on
its own i don't know if it's a
profession on its own but i know there
are certain psychologists and even
psychiatrists who do study the
interpretation of dreams there's
definitely like a name to this study
of dreams i can learn something too in
this video it's called
honoriology honoriology
honor rheology the study of honorology
can be distinguished from dream
interpretation in that the aim is to
quantitatively study the process of
dreams instead of analyzing the meaning
merker ermer serious question if ekg
means electrocardiogram then wouldn't it
be ecg it actually is ecg ekg is sort of
the old-school name from the german
definition electrocardiogram moves with
a k but now we do call it an ecg in fact
when i order on my computer i can either
put ekg or ecg it doesn't really matter
see ecg so we do call it ecg greg lydle
is picking your nose bad outside of the
risk of spreading germs etc greg this is
a great question a lot of people pick
their nose i think i've seen studies go
up as high as 90
of individuals at one point in time pick
their nose and i'm sure it's more than
that they're probably just that last
person's being i don't want to tell
anybody there are issues when you pick
your nose first and foremost trauma the
inside of your nose is more sensitive
than the outside of your nose so by
going inside and they're picking in
there especially with your fingernails
cause trauma cause nose bleeds
especially recurrent nosebleeds because
it takes forever for that area to
properly heal on top of it your fingers
aka your digits are the dirtiest meaning
the most bacteria and viruses live on
these bad boys so when you're putting
them in your nose where your mucous
membranes are that's a sure-fire way to
get sick in fact one of the biggest
things i recommend for people to avoid
catching the flu is to wash their hands
a and then b to not touch their face
means going in the nose one of the most
important methods to break a habit like
nose picking if you just have a habit
and you're not compulsive in doing it
put something on your finger like a
bandage that you use primarily to pick
your nostril because when you do it
you're going to remind yourself that oh
i shouldn't be doing it because
otherwise it can become really easy to
just keep doing it and please don't
don't go from the nose to the mouth
after
grovia springham if this old lady can
run her first half at 55 you can do it
two hours is not out of the question for
a healthy young guy good luck you got
this i appreciate the support grovia and
seriously amazing job doing a half
marathon of 55. amazing job doing a half
marathon period forget about your age if
you haven't seen this i'm gonna link it
down below nike and i have teamed up to
try out one of their new running
sneakers and i'm going to be running in
the la 13.1 half marathon in a month and
a half and i'm training right now but
it's a struggle i'm essentially going
from being a sprinter to a half marathon
runner in like 10 weeks for someone
who's never ran long distance that's
really tough and i'm 200 pounds these
thick dives save lives but hold me back
when it comes to running marathon you
jive
acureds is it possible that one day
medicine will not be effective anymore
since diseases like the flu keep
evolving and getting stronger the flu
does not necessarily get stronger it
just continually evolves in order to
keep surviving that's what sort of
nature's all about that's how we came to
be there will be certain medications
that will become less useful yes but at
the same time we'll create new
medications we'll learn new methods of
fighting off viruses and bacteria in
fact one of the main reasons why we
recommend to not overuse antibiotics is
to decrease this resistance that's
forming i have patients that i've
treated in the hospital that they have
bacteria that's resistant to every kind
of antibiotic that i can offer them
that's called a multi-drug resistant
organism and that's quite dangerous we
don't want these superbugs anywhere near
us so let's not take antibiotics when we
don't need them when doctors ask about
if you've been sexually active what
counts for medical purposes anything
involving the genital region should
count if it doesn't but you still think
it does say it there's no harm more
information is always better when it
comes to doctor's visits la anonymous
can you get a gallstone as a result of
stress after you lost your job had a
loved one pass etc thanks for answering
love your channel thanks for the love
you can get a gold stone anytime a lot
of times we don't even have a good
reason as to why they happen obviously
eating an unhealthy diet full of fried
fatty foods is not ideal and when one is
stressed you tend to eat more of those
types of foods so that can be a trigger
but in general we don't have great
evidence as to
why it happened in that specific moment
the same way that you know when you get
a cold or the flu can ask me all you
want why did i get it i don't have an
answer it just happens the lorax mike
there's no such thing as a dumb question
me how much feet are in seven minutes
yes or no
no
i don't know why but it's no think about
that lorax black and white i have a
question how do i send fanart to dr mike
p.o box baby which i haven't checked in
a while i probably should it's listed
down below it says please send me stuff
domagag lovasevic since higher body
temperature is a good thing when
fighting viruses at what temperature
should you take medicine to lower it
there's no specific temperature where
there's like a cut off if you're
becoming really uncomfortable you can't
sleep and rest and recover that could
also be an indication to do it in
general if i have a low fever 100.5 to
102.5 i tend to stick it out as much as
i can just because that will help my
body fight off the infection a little
bit better but again if you're
uncomfortable
you might need to take something
ronnie.bm here's a question do you wax
your hands or something
wax my hands
no i do not wax my hands that would be
strange cells at work is finally back
after my copyright challenge so click
here to check it out if you want me to
do a second episode definitely let me
know while staying happy and healthy
[Music]